[Musique]
le docteur scott green était jugé dans
une affaire de délit routier et c'est
depuis le bloc opératoire ils assistent
à l'audience en visioconférence en
découvrant cela le juge de sacramento
non droit le chirurgien esthétique lui
ne voit pas le problème nord
heureusement quand le patient le juge a
mis fin à l'audience et a reporté la
séance
les gendarmes de lannion ont été inclus
au sujet d'un tracteur circulant sur
l'autoroute a77 au niveau de tracy sur
loire les gendarmes l'interceptent
constatent que le conducteur est
complètement ivre mais au moment de
l'embarqué de leur demande s'il peut
aller récupérer quelques affaires là ou
alors son tracteur c'est alors qu'il
démarre et tentent de fuir une
incroyable course poursuite s'engage
un tracteur lancé à 30 à l'heure
arrêter les voleurs que faire la
matériel votre juron gros mot blasphème
favoris sans hésiter connard je répondis
à la parisienne quoique connard ou
kaunas
d'accord c'est pas pour toi connard et
uniquement masculin il ya autant de
kaunas que de connard après toi comment
les départager moitié pris l'avion le
week-end dernier week-end avant pour
entrer ni si on me faisait remettre mon
masque entre chaque bouchée pour mâcher
et alors qu'on te dit que dans l'avion
départ de vue les clim et le brassage
d'air et les filtrages ben yahya jammeh
une cluster m'a-t-on dit dans les avions
dans l'avion et contrôleurs de deuxième
monsieur marc chayer coup fini ces mots
debout je m'étais déjà jure
l'hôtesse est venu à côté de moi je
mange un sandwich à me dit monsieur vous
remettez votre masque entre chaque
bouchée
moi j'ai pris l'avion y avait carrément
pas de nourriture mais si j'avais acheté
un sandwich la finition j'ai fini mon
sandwich entre chaque bouchée et l'ont
alors qu'ils étaient tous là j'ai pas
mis cette rencontre s'assigne gros bébé
comme ça ça passe tellement vite
et moi je me rappelle c'est une petite
crevaison mais c'est compliqué à faire
le siège d'accouchement josé pas trop le
dire tout a lancé pour ça je me suis
précipité pour dans une posture délicate
décidément la parisienne excite les sens
108 s'affirme sous le second empire de
new york à moscou on l'a fantasme chic
et délurée un peu vous voyeuse
mais toujours voluptueuse
[Musique]
et de toutes les femmes du boulevard ce
sont les actrices qui l'incarnent
l'année avec deux mois de retard les
golden globes ont finalement eu lieu une
cérémonie virtuel présenté en simultané
depuis new york et los angeles par tina
fey à gauche et amy poehler à droite à
l'école
le golden globes est attribué à chaque
passage à double bosman pour le blues de
marine est sacré meilleur acteur six
mois après sa mort
l'émotion est à son comble quand la
femme de chadwick bozeman s'exprime il
remercierais dieu ses parents et ses
ancêtres qui ont fait des sacrifices et
lui ont ouvert la voie
la coface et enfin on termine avec borat
de et ses trois trophées pour sacha
baron cohen meilleure comédie meilleur
acteur dans une comédie et meilleure
vannes de la soirée joe biden a eu le
premier mois le plus désastreux car
président est connu depuis longtemps
c'est la vérité
[Applaudissements]
son administration a déjà prouvé qu'elle
était anti emploi anti famille antil
frontières anti énergie antil femmes et
anti science qui sait peut-être vais-je
décidé de les battre une troisième fois
en 48 peut-être plus j'ai les mêmes
initiales que napoléon bonaparte donc
attention nouvelle
peut-être que je suis sa petite fille
on ne sait pas encore avec défier
l'entente 2
[Musique]
allez avoue de remplacer deux lettres du
mot testicules en voyons avec les
lettres
oui bien sûr n et aa il faut qu'elle
soit tentacules dantec
on dit que certains mâles vont
développer ce qu'on appelle une odeurs
d'urines voilà qui est désagréable pour
le consommateur bano ici pour faire
simple ça fait sept ans qu'on arrêtait
de castres et nos animaux aucun pour
ceux des mâles nés castrés chez nous
ici comme dans un tiers des élevages
français ont de castres plus les cochons
et je peux vous dire qu à roquebrune cap
martin se trouve un olivier millénaire
il aurait entre 1800 et 2000 ans il
produit encore des petites olives noires
de la variété pitchouli n'a produit
également mais j'étais sûr cela ne
regarde personne
les problèmes intestinaux désert d
autres dont royan d'abord rien à faire
dans cette émission
et surtout on oublie pas l'important
c'est le coupé au montage
c'est la journée mondiale du compliment
est une journée qui a été créé aux
pays-bas en 2003 ya un certain nombre
d'années pour diffuser non positive dans
le monde entier et ça tombe à pic on en
a un peu besoin en ce moment
d'ailleurs je voulais vous dire où il
aime que je vous trouve très beau une
fois n'est pas coutume tandis que vous
c'est tous les jours que vous êtes belle
et compétente
ça c'est du compliment non et bien voilà